Chad GPT is changing the world as we
know it and today we are going to see
how it can give these incredible robots
a voice you will also be able to carry
it with you all day with this AI pin and
answer your questions on the go or you
can ask it to get this to also assemble
insanely complex robotic cows and it
might even be your doctor or at the very
least help your doctor but wait what do
these robots have to do with Chad GPT
Well Chad GPT is a helpful AI assistant
and since it now understands your speech
and can speak itself thus it can give a
voice to this robots what does that mean
well now it can help you and answer
questions and even show you around in
this building and it can do all this in
a fancy British accent uh Mr Matt my
employment as a tour guide provides
great
satisfaction I find the determination of
knowledge rather rewarding don't you
agree now behold the rock pile or it can
be an excited tour guide welcome to
Boston Dynamics I am spot your tour
guide robot let's explore the building
together or Josh this is where we
showcase our fastest four-legged robot
which can run up to 19 miles hour I hope
you're not too slow to keep up with it
or a teenager
like isn't it super cool how robots can
be involved in so many Industries these
are really authentic but I hope it is
not so authentic that the teenager
starts to throw Tantrums now also a
company called Humane has announced this
AI pin which is powered by Chad GPT and
it can be your interpreter what should I
get
here help you find your way around the
city with a projected screen and more
you don't even have to use your
smartphone for these interactions and
with this CAD GPT can be with you all
day long it has become an integral part
of our Lives it is absolutely everywhere
mat what is the deal with these crazy
robotic cows dear fellow Scholars this
is 2minute papers with Dr Caro here well
that is a task from the USA Computing
Olympiad this is a problem where we are
supposed to build a robotic cow herd and
where the answer to the question
requires coding app a computer program
according to the Computing Olympiad the
level of difficulty of this task is
insane in my opinion it is not that bad
but let's see what C GPT thinks now
let's give it this problem and oh look
at that beauty it seems to understand
the problem and dutifully starts writing
the code nice it says the solution is
61 is that correct oh boy it is good job
little AI a perhaps insane level problem
but for Chad G PT not a problem at all
now I Wonder has it seen this problem
before well you know what just for fun
let's ask Chad GPT itself so have you
seen this task before and it says that
it hasn't good but wait when I ask would
you know if you had already seen it it
says no that is hilarious love it but is
this some new capability or could even a
previous version of it perform these
calculations let's see this is version
3.5 it is extremely fast I like it and
not quite version 3.5 5 cannot solve it
correctly this is something that is no
capability also neither can Google deep
Minds new Gemini not even close and
speaking of amazing new capabilities
look at this this paper was written as a
collaboration with a board certified
radiologist and here gp4 can do two
things really well first is identifying
diseases now hold on to your papers
fellow Scholars because in many tasks
the rate of mistakes is less than 1%
nearly perfect what this is as good as
the best techniques out there in many
cases and in some cases it is crowned as
the new best one I am out of words wow
and two it can also create easy to read
summaries for the patients here in the
majority of cases it is not only
comparable but its summaries are even
preferred when compared to the ones
written by a real doctor and at this
point I will add a strong caveat to this
this is just a really brief look please
know that anything in this area requires
really careful evaluation and whenever
they ask a doctor about these findings
there is always something that they
point out that may be missing for
instance here maybe a real doctor has to
to write up a huge amount of summaries
per day and maybe they are using more
abbreviations and shortcuts an AI never
gets tired and can do thousands of these
in a matter of seconds does this mean
that it is better not necessarily the
human written one may be just as
understandable so the bottom line is
that things are messy in this domain and
evaluation is subjective this shows that
ch GPT is a Swiss army knife it can do
so much this is perhaps a new kind of
Intelligence being born right before our
eyes fellow Scholars and we also found
out recently that Chad GPT remembers
what does that mean well have a look
this is cloud 2.1 a competing chatbot
from anthropic and it has a context
window of about 200k tokens now in
intuitively this means that in a single
prompt you can shovel in about 500 pages
of material you can check a whole
textbook in there and talk to it or get
it to summarize huge and boring budget
reports that is amazing however wait
look at this context length is one
variable but being able to recall all
this information is also important and
when asking question questions about the
document it matters where in this
document the information was for
instance if it was early on it might be
forgotten by the time it reads until the
end on the other hand CAD gpt's contact
length is about half of this but look at
all the beautiful green you see that
this is a tradeoff a bigger context
length may be created but at the cost of
fidelity not even ching GPT is perfect
not even close but you see that its
Fidelity is incredible so Chad GPT
remembers and don't forget this is
something that was just a paper four
years ago and today it is taking the
World by storm it is now out there in
the real world solving real problems
that were previously almost impossible
and it is now an integral part of our
Lives how cool is that what a time to be
alive if you enjoyed this episode and
you wish to see more consider
subscribing and hitting the Bell icon
when I was a PhD student my experiments
created lots of data for my deep
learning projects but I was not looking
for more data I was looking for insights
this is what weights and biases does and
it is the best everyone is using it try
it out now at wb. me/ papers or click
the link in the description below